le préfet de police de paris didier
lallement vient de s'exprimer il exhorte
les parisiens à faire preuve de
discipline écoutez la vous observerez
que il y a des moments dans la journée
au cours desquelles la présence d'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens est
supérieur ça peut être le cas dans les
marchés je l'évoquais les bords de seine
nous avons été qu'il y avait des
horaires de fréquentation donc il n'y a
pas d'endroit
il y à certains moments au cours
desquelles des certains de nos
concitoyens se regroupent et se
rassemblent donc nous allons essayer
progressivement de leur expliquer de les
convaincre que cette discipline
collective est impératif c'est vraiment
5 je veux dire aujourd'hui nous sommes
vraiment tous mobilisés les efforts que
font la plupart de notre citoyens sont
remarquables rester chez soi toute la
journée et surtout quand il fait beau
comme aujourd'hui c'est particulièrement
pénible mais ça n'est qu'à la condition
que l'ensemble de la population le fond
ce que laisse que le résultat sera sera
probant